after selecting a Dom element you can
set and get the CSS styles of the
element so here's the HTML here and the
HTML is being rendered down here and you
can see that we have an idea of line for
this paragraph tag and we have an ID of
attribute here for this paragraph tag
here we have an inline style making this
bold and if you look up this at the CSS
we've also added this CSS year so we've
created the body and made the font size
30 pixels and we're just gonna close the
CSS here you can see for the JavaScript
we've already selected two things so in
the line variable
we've got Ellen by ID line that's this
first one the first paragraph tag then
we get element by ID attribute that's
the the second paragraph tag here so I
want to change the CSS style of the line
so we have line dot style dot color so
line refers to this variable right here
that get element by ID line then you put
style because we're changing the style
and then we want to change the color
style and we're gonna set that to red so
if I run that you'll see now we have red
text you can also change this to
background and we're gonna make the
background red there are a lot of
different words you can put here to
change the different CSS style elements
if you check the link in the description
you can see a list of all the CSS style
elements that you can change now here's
another example we're going to set the
attribute
let's get element by ID attribute here
the style and the box shadow we're gonna
set this to this box shadow and now we
have a box shadow down here so here
we're just setting one style property at
a time but there are two ways that you
can set a lot of style properties at
once and we're using line style dot CSS
text and then you can see I've put in
multiple Styles color blue
and then you separate with a semicolon
border and adding a border here or you
can set the attribute of style you set
attribute now notice we don't have the
word style anymore it's just a tribute
dot set attribute and we're going to
tribute just a name from up here but you
always have to use this set attribute
and set the attribute of style and then
you can put multiple styles that you
want to set here one thing about this
though that you need to know is that
once we've run this you can see that we
have the Styles here this line is no
longer bold we have an inline style up
here to make this line bold but when you
set all the Styles at once with either
CSS text or set attribute it's going to
remove any inline styles and just
replace all of the inline Styles with
whatever you are setting here sometimes
it can be better just to set one style
at a time if you don't want to get rid
of the other styles that already exist
now let me show you two ways you can
figure out what styles are already on an
element okay open up the log here and
I'm going to put okay console dot log
line that style so up here we were
sitting line that style dot background
to equal red and now we're just gonna
console dot log line that style now if I
put line that style dot background it
will just show what the background color
is but if I do line that style and don't
put that background it's going to show
every style element so let me run that I
can show you that and if I expand this
this is another way of seeing every
style element that you can set with
JavaScript and this is going to show a
list of every style element you can see
we have border left here this is set
border color is black a lot of things
that are not set you can see a lot of
these just have an empty string we don't
have anything set for most of these but
we do have the color
as blue one thing that you'll notice
here if I go back to the CSS over in the
code and we see we have font size 30
pixels well let's look at the font size
in here
font size is showing as an empty stream
here that is because when you are
logging the style or working with this
style here it's only going to show the
inline styles and remember this up here
is adding an inline style this will not
show any other styles that just happen
to be on the element for instance it's
not going to show this style because
it's not an inline style it just happens
to also apply to that element now there
is a way to get all the styles even
styles that are not in line on the
element and that's with get computed
style so let me show you that now this
is a little different I'm not calling it
on the line variable that I set up here
I'm actually calling it on the window
object window dot get computed style and
then I have to pass in the Dom element I
have to pass in this line variable that
we created up here to get the computed
style on the line and now it's going to
show everything even computed styles so
as an example if we go down to yeah font
size font size is 30 pixels and now none
of these are showing empty strings
because everything is something we even
have a height of 36 pixels now we never
set the height of 36 pixels that's just
the actual height so everything like
before when we console dot log just
style a lot of them would be empty
strings because they were never
specifically set but when we use get
computed style it's gonna show what the
style is even if you never said it well
thanks for watching check the
description for a link to the code from
this video my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good